اصيب سته عشر فلسطينيه بينهم صحفيون اثر
اطلاق قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الرصاصه
الحيه والمعدنيه على مئات الفلسطينيين في
مدينه رام الله ليله الخميس وكانت قوات
الاحتلال قد اقتحمت رام الله باكثر من
خمسين اليه عسكريه وفرضت عليها حصارا قبل
تفجيرها منزل عائله الاسير اسلام فروخ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما الرسائل التي تريد اسرائيل
توجيهها باقتحام مدينه رام الله في سياق
اقتحاماتها المستمره لمدن الضفه الغربيه
بعد اسابيع قليله فقط من اتفاقي شرم الشيخ
والعقبه لخفض صيد الاسرائيلي وعوده
التنسيق مع السلطه
وما خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه للتعامل مع
هذا الوضع في المرحله المقبله وما مصير
تلك الاتفاقيات الاخيره وما توصلت اليه من
تفاهمات في ظل عدم التزام اسرائيل بها
وكيف يبدو موقف واشنطن راعيه السلام
والمشرفه عن تلك الاتفاقيات من التصايد
الاسرائيليه المتكرر ضد الفلسطينيين
ومرؤيتها لتحقيق الاستقرار في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والمنطقه
[موسيقى]
في سياق اقتحامات اصبحت شبه يوميا لمدن
الضفه الغربيه وبعد السويعات من مباحثات
الامريكي مع مسؤولين فلسطينيين في رام
الله ميشان التصيد الاسرائيلي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بعد كل ذلك سقط 16 جريحا
فلسطينيا بينهم صحفيون في مواجهات ليله
الخميس بالبلده القديمه في مدينه رام الله
بين شبان الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت المدينه باكثر من
50 اليه عسكريه تساعدها طائره مسيره وذلك
تمهيدا لتفجير منزل عائله الاسير اسلام
الفاروخ والتي القت السلطات الاسرائيليه
القبض عليه في السابع والعشرين من ديسمبر
كانون الاول الماضي بتهمه تخطيط وتنفيذ
تفجيرين وقع في القدس في نوفمبر الثاني
الماضي واسفر عن مقتل اسرائيليين
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من نرى
رام الله الدكتور حسين حمايل المتحدث
باسمي حركه فتح ومن رام الله ايضا ينضم
الينا دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كان ينضم
الينا من واشنطن ريتشارد غوتشتاين المبعوث
الخاص السابق للرئيس كلينتون الى مفاوضات
السلام بالشرق الاوسط اهلا بكم جميعا في
هذه الحلقه وابدا من رام الله والدكتور
حسين حمايل
اقتحامات طبعا شبه يوميه للمدن الفلسطينيه
في رام الله
كيف تتابع السلطه كل هذا التصعيد
يعني اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه هي مكون من مكونات
الشعب الفلسطيني يتم الاعتداء على كافه
مؤسسات هذه السلطه ومؤسسات الشعب
الفلسطيني من قبل قوات الاحتلال في ظل
الصمت الدولي للاسف الشديد صمتا دوليا
مريبا وكذلك
تطبيقا لعقليه اسرائيليه متطرفه في حكومه
اكثر فاشيه واكثر تطرفا في تاريخ دوله
الاحتلال وهذه الحكومه للاسف الشديد يعني
لولا الصمت الدولي وكذلك
الصمت من الكثير من اشقائنا العرب
والمسلمين
ووقوف الدعم الامريكي المادي لدوله
الاحتلال لما كان هذا يحدث في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وما كان هذا لهذا الاجرام ان
يستمر ضد ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني بالنسبه
لنا نحن كفلسطينيين اعتقد ان المشاهد التي
كانت بالامس في مدينه رام الله من تصدي
الشبان الفلسطينيين لهذه القوه كبيره من
قبل قوات جيش الاحتلال التي دخلت الى
مدينه رام الله هو رساله نبرق من خلالها
الى العالم اجمع باننا كفلسطينيين ما تقوم
به اسرائيل من قتل للشباب الفلسطيني
ولابناء الشعب الفلسطيني وهدم للبيوت لن
يزيد هذا الشعب الا اصرارا والا اقداما
والا تصميما على الخلاص من هذا الاحتلال
نعم نعم نحن ننظر بنظره واقعيه لهذا الحال
ننظر بان هناك عدم تكافؤ للفرص عدم تكافؤ
للفرص من ناحيه القوه العسكريه التي
تملكها اسرائيل مقابل الشعب الفلسطيني
شعبا اعزلا اذا ما قرن بما تملكه اسرائيل
من ادوات وامكانيات في
قواتها العسكريه ولكن نحن كفلسطينيين نحن
كفصائل عمل وطني فلسطيني نقول ومن خلال
الجزيره ومن خلال كل الفضائيات اننا
سنستمر في مقاومه هذا الاحتلال
بامكانياتنا على هذه الارض في الامر ليس
في رام الله الامر في كل المدن الفلسطينيه
يتعرض الشعب الفلسطيني لاجرام يومي لهدم
للبيوت
لسلب للاراضي وكذلك اطلاق العنان
للمستوطنين اليوم اسرائيل تاتي بهؤلاء
الحثاله المستوطنين الى الجبال والى
التلال من اجل ان يقوموا بالاستيلاء على
الاراضي بخطه اسرائيليه ممنهجه تدعمها
مكونات دوله الاحتلال
ليخلقوا امرا واقعا ويعتقدوا واهمين بان
الشعب الفلسطيني من خلال هذا الامر الواقع
الذي سيخوه على الارض سيستسلم وسيسلم بما
يقوم فيه ولكن نحن سنستمر حاله الجبن
وحاله الرعب التي تلف جنود الاحتلال في
دخولهم في هذه القوه العسكريه الضخمه جدا
الى مدينه رام الله تؤكد بان من يقوم على
روايه كل هذه القوه العسكريه الضخمه دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي من رساله التي تريد
ارسالها اسرائيل من وراء هذا التصيد وبهذه
القوه العسكريه الضخمه
الرساله واضحه وان اسرائيل تستخف بالجميع
تستخف بالسلطه الفلسطينيه
وبكل من شاركوا في اجتماع شرم الشيخ وقبل
ذلك في اجتماع العقبه وهذا الذي جرى يؤكد
مدى الخطا الذي ارتكبته السلطه الفلسطينيه
بذهابها الى شرم الشيخ اسرائيل كل ما جرى
في شرم الشيخ مزقته ورمت به في سله
المهملات في الاجتياحات هي تجتاح جميع
مناطق السلطه الفلسطينيه دون استثناء طول
كرم جنين نابلس اريحا
رام الله عندما
ذهبت الى شرم الشيخ والعقبه
طبعا وتخطئ اكثر باستمرارها في التنسيق
الامني مع الجانب الاسرائيلي في ظل هذا
الاجرام الذي يمارس ضدها وضد الشعب
الفلسطيني والامر الثاني الذي ذكر في تلك
الاجتماعات انه سيجري وقف المشاريع
الاستيطاني الجديده ما الذي يجري اليوم
الحديث يدور عن تشريع سبعين مستوطنه جديده
وبداوا ببناء 13 مستعمره جديده
واعلنوا عودتهم الى حومش حتى في جنين
واضيفي الى ذلك عمليات الاغتيال والقتل
التي راينا ابشع صورها قبل يومين في النبي
صالح عندما قاموا باغتيال الطفل محمد
التميمي عمره عامين هو والده قاموا
باغتيالهم امام منزلهم لم يقوموا باي شيء
ان الذي نراه هجمه شرسه وادعيني اشير ايضا
الى ان اسرائيل ايضا تعمل على امر خطير
رابع اخر وهو تشجيع الفلتان الامني
والجريمه المنظمه بهدف زعزعه المجتمع
الفلسطيني في فلسطين
وفي الاراضي المحتله كما راينا اليوم في
يافه الناصره بسقوط خمس اشخاص بالرصاص
هناك نحن نتحدث عن مؤامره خطيره تشنها
اسرائيل وهذا يستدعي رد فعل مختلف يستدعي
توحيد الصرف الوطني على برنامج كفاحي
دكتور
اقتحام بهذا العنف بهذا الكم الهائل من
القوات الاسرائيليه ياتي فقط ساعات بعد
لقاء مسؤولينا فلسطينيين مع المبعوث
الاممي الى الاراضي الامريكيه الى الاراضي
الفلسطينيه كيف نفهم هذه المفارقه برايك
سواء
فان اسرائيل لديها ممارسه وهي انه عندما
يحددون شخصا ما
يعتقدونه هو الذي فجر موقف سيارات عامه
وقتل وجرح كثير من الاسرائيليين بالنسبه
لهم انه لابد ان ينتقموا من ذلك بالتدمير
منزل من قام بذلك انا افهم بالكثيرين
الذين يعتبرون هذه جريمه حرب لكن
وسيله ردع انا تخميني ان اسرائيل
شاطره مع مسؤولين الولايات المتحده خططها
واعتقد ان كان لديهم مثل هذه الحضور
العسكري كبير لانهم لم يكونوا يريدون
لخبراء التدمير ان
يتعرضوا للهجوم نحن هنا مره اخرى قل لا
يتعب فقط اطلاق صواريخ ضد ضد دبابات
اسرائيليه بل القنابل ايضا قد تكون خطيره
جدا طبعا لذلك اعتقد لان هذا يدل على ان
ليس على التزام بالمقاومه وانا افهم لو
انا كنت فلسطينيا نعم هذه الرساله لكن انا
فمه ان هذا يؤكد لنا لماذا ان السلام مهم
جدا ان اسرائيل لن تنسحب
شهادنا وفعلوا ذلك انسحبوا من غزه انسحب
تمام من غزه والنتيجه كانت الاف والاف
والاف من الصواريخ تطلق من غزه على
اسرائيل انا لا اعتقد ان اسرائيل تعتقد ان
هذه نتيجه جيده لو انسحبوا من الضفه
الغربيه
السلام هو
الشيء الوحيد هنا وانا افهم ان ذلك صعب
لان حكومه نتنياهو ومع موجود في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه الذي لا يمكن ان يفكر ويقبلوا
السلام
تاخذ راي الدكتور حسين الحمايل والدكتور
برغوثي على كلامك على هذا التبرير لما
تفعله اسرائيل كيف ترد دكتور حسين على ما
قدمه السيد جوستان من تبرير لما تفعله
اسرائيل
يعني اولا يتكلم وكانه هو الناطق باسم جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو يغفل عن الجرائم
التي تقوم بها اسرائيل في قتل الاطفال
والابرياء ولم يذكر اليوم عندما تكلم عن
هدم البيت لعائله اسلام الفروخ وهو ليس
الاسلام فروخ هو لعائله اسلام الفروق لم
يتكلم عن قتل قوات الاحتلال للطفل محمد
التميمي بالامس ولم يتكلم عن قتل 11
فلسطيني في جنين ولم يتكلم عن مئه شهيد
اكثر من 160 شهيد فلسطيني ارتقوا منذ
بدايه هذا العام يعني استغرب انه السيد
عندما يكون مبعوثا
للسلام الذي يتكلم فيه الى المنطقه ان
يتكلم بهذه الروايه ويحاول ان يوازن ما
بين اجرام دوله الاحتلال وما بين الضحايا
التي تقع في الجانب الفلسطيني في عدم
تكافؤ التكافؤ الميزان القوه ما بين
الماكنه الاسرائيليه
المدعومه من المتحده الامريكيه التي يشارك
اليوم من حيث لا يدروا دافعوا الضرائب في
امريكا في قتل اطفال فلسطين ويتكلم عن
عشرات بل مئات الشهداء في غزه الذين
قتلتهم اسرائيل من خلال الطائرات
الاسرائيليه التي تقوم بقصف الاحياء وقصف
المساكن في المقابل لم يقتل من الجانب
الاسرائيلي من خلال الصواريخ التي بدا
التي تطلقها فصائل المقاومه في من غزه منذ
يعني في اربع حروب متتاليه
يعني العدد نسبه وتناسب لا يتجاوز الواحد
في المئه ما بين ما تقوم به اسرائيل من
اجرام ضد ابناء الشعبي
نعم هذا مفهوم ولكن امام كل هذه الجرائم
كما تقول كان يعاتب دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
قبل قليل كان عاتب السلطه الفلسطينيه على
انها رغم كل ذلك ذهبت الى العقبه وذهبت
الى شرم الشيخ وعادت مره اخرى الى التنسيق
الامني انت كمتحدث باسم حركه فتح كيف ترد
على هذا الكلام
يعني اولا اختي نحن كفلسطينيين يعني انا
ما بدي ادخل في سجال الان مع الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي في النهايه الحكه
الفلسطينيين
يوحدنا الدم يوحدنا الاجرام الذي تكون به
اسرائيل ولكن يابل بعض يعني بهمش يسمح لي
في هذا العتب البسيط في دكتور مصطفى انه
يحاول ان من خلال الشعارات ان يحرر الارض
الموضوع اخي دكتور مصطفى انت لم تذهب الى
شرم الشيخ ورافض لشرم الشيخ ماذا فعلت منذ
اللقاءات التي حصلت يعني ماذا فعلت على
الارض حتى تاتي لتتكلم نحن فلسفه السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي ندعمها نحن كحركه فتح
القياده السياسيه الفلسطينيه التي ندعم
مواقفها ايضا نحن كحركه فت نحن على
استعداد ان نقعد مع الصديق ومع العدو ومع
المطبع ومن كل ومع كل شخص نجد هناك بصيصا
للامل لحمايه
يعني احنا ايضا كفت حاويين وكذلك القياده
السياسيه الفلسطينيه ليست بساذجه عندما
تذهب الى العقبه وهي يعني لم نقل نامل بان
تحرر فلسطين بعد عودتنا من العقبه الموضوع
مش هيك الموضوع ان هناك اجرام يومي يتصاعد
ضد ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني وسمعت روايه
كوردشتاين قبل قليل عندما قال انه يعني
اسرائيل هذا الطفل الوديع يا حرام بتدافع
عن انفسها في هذا البيوت يا اخي مشان
الانسانيه مشان مشان التاريخ والتمثال
الحريه اخي
الحقيقه في هذا الموضوع اكمل لك اختي اذا
سمحتي
وعمليا احنا من حقنا احنا من حقنا يا اختي
احنا من حقنا كفلسطينيين ان نذهب الى اي
مكان العقبه كانت فيه الاداره الامريكيه
على الورق بحكوا كلام حلو ولكن للاسف
اسرائيل تستمر في اجرامها بسبب الدعم
الامريكي اذا امتلكت الاداره الامريكيه
الان الاراده لوقف هذا الاجرام بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني هنا انا بحكي لك سيتحقق الكلام
الذي يحاول ان يعمل له دعايه الان
غوتشتاين
هذا الكلام احنا الوقت كله ولكن سامحني
فقط لانه بقي معنا عشر دقائق ويجب ان اعطي
الكلمه ايضا للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي في
هذه النقطه الان وصلت الامور يعني الى
العظم الى رام الله على يعني كما يقال على
مرمى حجر من مقر السلطه ما الخيارات التي
يمكن ان تواجه بها السلطه وكان قد بدا
الحديث عن ذلك الدكتور حسين ما الخيارات
ماذا يمكن ان تفعل السلطه امام كل هذا
اولا كما قال الاخ حسين نحن جميعا في خندق
واحد طبعا ضد الاحتلال وضد ظل ضد الانحياز
الامريكي المطلق لاسرائيل ولكن انا كنت
اتمنى ان لا يدافع عن الذهاب الى شرم
الشيخ ولا الى العقبه وهو يسالني ماذا
افعل انا افعل الكثير مثل غيري من كل
ابناء وبنات الشعب الفلسطيني الذين
يقاومون الاحتلال بكل الوسائل مثل الشباب
الفلسطيني الذي تصدى امس لقوات الاحتلال
بكل ما لديه باجساده العاريه ووقف في
وجههم مثل المقاومه الفلسطينيه الباسله
التي تقوم بالتصدي للاحتلال بكل الاشكال
بالمقاومه الشعبيه بالمقاومه المسلحه
بالمقاومه على الصعيد الدولي في كل
المجالات وهذا ما نريد ان يفعله الجميع
لا مبرر كل الشعب الفلسطيني كل الشعب
الفلسطيني اقتنع بانه كان من الخطا الذهاب
الى شرم الشيخ ومن الخطا الاستمرار في
التنسيق الامني
ما هو معنى التنسيق الامني عندما تختفي
القوى الامنيه من شوارع رام الله ويدخل
جيش الاحتلال بخمسين مدرعه ما معنى
التنسيق الامني وما قيمته ان كان عاجزا عن
ان يدافع عن الفلسطينيين في وجه
المستوطنين المنفلتين من عقالهم ويعتدون
على الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن انا لا اريد ان
اضيع الوقت في السجال مع اخي حسين انا
اريد ان اتحدث عن ما قاله المتحدث
الامريكي باختصار المتحدث فعلا هذا متحدث
يتحدث باسم الاحتلال ويكرر اقاويل اسرائيل
الكاذبه اسرائيل لم تنسحب اسرائيل ما زالت
تحاصر غزه برا
برا نعم المندوب الامريكي نعم الممثل ما
قاله المتحدث الامريكي ليس غير ليس صحيحا
اسرائيل لم تنسحب من غزه اسرائيل ما زالت
تحاصر غزه
طيب
لو سمحت بس اجيبك على سؤالك اجيبك على
سؤالك ما يجب ان تفعل السلطه الفلسطينيه
برايي ان تتجه للوحده الوطنيه لتوحيد الصف
الوطني على برنامج وطني كفاحي مقاوم
والتخلي عن نهج التفاوض الذي فشل وعندما
يقال الامريكي الامريكان حكوا كلام معسول
المؤمن لا يلدغ من جحر مرتين امريكا بتحكي
انه الاستيطان عقبه وامس بلنكن اعلن عن
منح اسرائيل مليار دولار جديد لتسليحها
وتسليح القبه الحديديه يكفينا خداع للنفس
يكفينا اتكال على الولايات المتحده
كيف نفهم هذا التناقض في الموقف
الامريكي وهي التصريحات الرسميه لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول انه مع حل عادل
وحل الدولتين وفي نفس الوقت مليار دولار
تطوير السلاح الاسرائيلي كيف نفهم هذا
التناقض في الموقف الامريكي
في الواقع
هي ديمقراطيه
وهي
قد تقترب من الابتعاد عن بعض
المبادئيه مثل القضاء المستقر ولكنها
حليفه
وتؤمن بحريه التعبير وحريه قدره الناس على
العباده عباده الهه مختلفه وهذا امر هو
اساس في العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل حقيقه ان ان هناك اختلاف هذا
بالتاكيد اختلاف بين مساعدات تقدمها
الولايات المتحده لاسرائيل
والمساعدات الولايات المتحده
للسلطه الفلسطينيه هذا لا
يؤثر او لا يقل من شان الالتزام الولايات
المتحده بحل الدولتين
انا اعتقد لكنك اعتراف بان الطرفين طرفي
الدولتين ينبغي انه بانفسهما ان يروا ذلك
على هو حل ونتيجه مقبوله وجيده فاسرائيل
وافقا على اتفاقيه سنه مع مصر ومع الاردن
ولذيذه الان اتفاقات مع الامارات العربيه
المتحده والبحرين وهذا هو هذا امر ما كان
متوقعا قبل بضع سنوات وبالتالي الامر ممكن
ممكن انه لهذا الاتفاقيات ان تستمر وتصمد
ولكن على الطرفين ان يلتزم بها ولا اعتقد
انك ادله على الولايات المتحده تحاول ان
نعم المشكله الاساسيه هي مع الفلسطينيين
وليس مع الدول التي طب العربيه التي طبعت
معها اسرائيل دعني انقل هذا الكلام الى
دكتور حسين حمايل مع كل ما قاله سيد غول
هل ما زالت او ما زال الفلسطينيون وما
زالت السلطه الفلسطينيه تراهن على دور
حقيقي وفعال للاداره الامريكيه لوواشنطن
في اداره هذا الصراع في التوسط في حل هذا
الصراع
يا اختي نراهن على انفسنا نراهن على
صمودنا نراهن على عداله قضيتنا بما صدر عن
الامم المتحده وصدر عن عن كل المؤسسات
الدوليه بان هذه دوله دوله فلسطين نحن
نطالب بانه من اعلن دوله اسرائيل عندما
اعلنت هذا اعلن هذا الجسم الغريب في
المنطقه الذي يتكلم عنه اعلن في المقابل
بان يكون هناك دوله فلسطينيه وما زال
العالم يدعم اسرائيل بالنيرات لقتل
الفلسطينيين وما زال العالم لا يقف عند
مسؤولياته بما يخصنا
سنستمر سنستمر من اجل ان نحق الحق
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور حسين حمايل المتحدث
باسم حركه فتح من رام الله وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ونشكر ضيفنا ايضا من مارشن
ريتشارد غوتستاين المبعوثه الخاص السابق
للرئيس كلينسون الى مفاوضات السلام بالشرق
الا وسط شكرا لكم جميعا وبهذا ناتي الى
ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج مورو الخبر لكم
منا اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]